Well, the title of this lecture is a
woman rides the beast because that's
exactly what it says in the book of
Revelation.
In the last lecture that we had on
Revelation chapter 13, we looked at the
various issues pertaining to the papal
power and the power that arises out of
the earth and we identified that as the
United States which would force the
world to accept legislation honoring the
first beast. Now that is a process which
will have to continue over all the
kingdoms of the world. Now Revelation
chapter 17 gives us more details on this
issue.
And there came one of the seven angels
which had the seven vials and talked
with me saying unto me, come hither, and
I will show ye the judgment of the great
These are strong words that
siteth upon many waters. So here is a
woman that is a prostitute. In other
words, she is unfaithful to God. A woman
in a biblical sense is a church. And
there are numerous texts in the Old and
the New Testament to substantiate this.
Christ is also the husband. He's coming
to fetch his bride, the church, the
woman aspect over there.
So this great apostate woman sits on
many waters. And we saw that the waters
are multitudes, nations, peoples,
tongues according to the definition in
Revelation itself.
And with this woman, the kings of the
earth have committed fornication. That
means they have had relationships with
her which were of course contrary to the
relations that God would like them to
have. and the inhabitants of the earth
have been made drunk with the wine of
her fornication.
That would mean if wine is a symbol of
teachings, doctrines, then uh wine of
fornication that makes drunk is doctrine
that confuses the mind. So basically
what it the text says is that a church
an apostate church is in control of
issues. The kings of the world have
relations with this apostate church and
they are drunk. They cannot understand
because they have absorbed these
doctrines which are contrary to the
Bible because they are doctrines of
prostitution.
So he carried me away in the spirit into
the wilderness
and I saw a woman sit upon a
scarletcoled beast. So here is a red
color. This is a color of sacrifice.
And it was full of names of blasphemy.
So it is a blasphemous power. And we saw
what that meant when we looked at
Revelation chapter 13. And the Bible
gives us clues by showing that to say
that you are in the place of God, that
you are God on earth, that you can
forgive sins, that you can take that
which applies to Christ and apply it to
yourself, that's a blasphemy. And we saw
that the Roman church had actually done
that. So this woman sitting on this
scarlet beast full of the names of
blasphemy, having seven heads and 10
horns. And that of course again is the
symbol that we had in Revelation chapter
13. If you count the heads that we have
in all the beasts of Daniel chapter 7,
you will find that there are seven heads
there as well because the first beast
obviously has one head over there which
represents Babylon, the lion. Meo Persia
has one head. Greece is represented
having four heads and then one head of
the final beast in Daniel chapter 7 adds
up to seven heads. That means over time
all the time periods are covered and
have been incorporated into this one
structure. This Catholicism structure
has aspects of all the philosophies of
all the kingdoms of the ages embodied in
it. It has perfected paganism. if you
would like to call it that. The woman
was arrayed in purple and scarlet, two
colors which applied definitely to the
Roman church. They used the colors
purple and they used the colors red for
cardinals and for bishops
and decked with gold and precious stones
and pearls. There's no doubt that this
is the richest system that has ever
existed. having a golden cup in her hand
full of abominations and filthiness of
her fornication.
So this golden cup is full of false
doctrines. And upon her forehead was a
name written mystery. That means it is a
concealed
science if you like. Babylon the great
the mother of harlots which implies that
there are others other women if you like
that are also apostate but she is the
mother of them all
and abominations of the earth. This is
very strong language and we will have to
see if this is so.
Well, let's have a look at the
sevenheaded beast. In Psalm 74:14, we
read, "Thou breakest the heads of
Leviatan in pieces, and gavest him to be
meat food to the people inhabiting the
wilderness." So here is a beast that is
described as Leviatan, a dragonlike
beast. And it is implied that it has
more than one head. In mythology,
Leviatan has seven heads. Isaiah chapter
27:E1.
In that day the Lord with his sore and
great and strong sword shall punish
Levatan
the piercing servant, even Leviatan,
that crooked serpent. And he shall slay
the dragon that is in the sea. Isn't
that interesting?
Slay the dragon that is in the sea. Do
you remember that? We had some
interesting symbolism when we looked at
marality where Mary is called the star
of the sea. Interesting interesting uh
analogies. Revelation 12:3. And there
appeared another wonder in heaven. And
behold, a great red dragon having seven
heads and 10 horns. So here we have a
dragon in Isaiah.
And we don't know how many heads it has.
We have a levatan in Psalm 74:14,
which is applied to the dragon in Isaiah
27:1.
And in Revelation, we see that it has
seven horns. Can you see how it all fits
together? If you'll use parallelism, you
can find all the heads that you need.
And seven crowns upon his heads.
So this dragon in Revelation 12 is a
ruling power. He is in control. He is
the prince of this world. Jesus called
Satan the prince of this world.
Revelation 13:1. And I stood upon the
sand of the sea and saw a beast rise up
out of the sea having seven heads and 10
horns and upon his horns 10 crowns and
upon his heads the name of blasphemy.
So here we have now a division into 10
horns. That's 10 kingdoms. Upon the
horns 10 crowns that means the beast
ruled with these 10 kingdoms. That's the
time of the Middle Ages when Rome ruled
by means of the powers of Europe.
Revelation 17:3. And so I car carried me
away in the spirit into the wilderness,
and I saw a woman upon a scarlet-c
colored beast full of the names of
blasphemy, having seven heads and 10
horns. Obviously, this is the
representation of the kingdom of Satan
throughout all the ages. And in
Revelation 17, we're going to have the
culmination of his power in the final
events just before the coming of Christ.
So the dragon has seven heads. In the
book of Revelation, the heads denote
political powers
through whom the dragon works. But just
for interest sake, it is interesting
that Satan tried seven times to set up
his own unchallenged kingdom.
Firstly, there was a war in heaven and
God's response was expulsion of Satan
from heaven.
Then Adam and Eve and the pre flood
world, he tried to set up his kingdom.
God's response to Adam and Eve, promise
of redemption, sacrificial system.
Then Tower of Babel was his next attempt
to set up unity of all the nations on
earth. God's response confusion of
tongues separating the nations.
Interesting.
Then during the incarnation, he thought
if he can destroy Christ, he can set up
his kingdom.
Victory over sin and death was God's
response.
turning the greatest apparent defeat
into the greatest victory the universe
had ever seen. He tried to set up his
kingdom through pagan Rome and the
answer smir resolve. People were
prepared to die rather than to be
eliminated. He tried to set up his uh
system through papal Rome. The answer
reformation.
Nowhere could he succeed. Will there be
a final time when he will try and set up
his kingdom? Something where all the
nations come together in one great new
world order. Is that possible? That
would be interesting. Seven times he
would have tried. And there is an answer
which I've called here midnight and loud
cry. But we'll deal with that in another
lecture. It's kind of complicated.
Revelation 12:3 says, "And there
appeared another wonder in heaven, and
behold, a great red dragon having seven
heads and 10 horns and seven crowns upon
his head. This power was going to make
war against another system of on earth,
obviously representing God's people."
And so there is a dragon and it attacks
the woman in white. And this war will
continue until the coming of Christ. So
the Bible says. So this creature that we
found in Revelation 13 that came out of
the sea tell uh tells us what the
attributes of the papal power are
because this is a system that has all
the attributes of the little horn power
in Daniel chapter 7. So it is the same
system and it tells us that it has Meo
Persian components because it has the
feet of the bear. It has Greek
philosophy in it which tells us the
whole evolution theory by the way is
based on Greek philosophy and comes from
there. It has Greek components in it. It
has the Babylonian components in. That
would take a whole lecture to show the
comparison between Babylonian religion
and Catholicism. There's a lecture
called the wine of Babylon that you
could look at for that purpose. And then
it has the 10 horns which represent this
final power which would control
eventually the whole world. So, heads of
lions with 10
horns.
And a woman is of course the church
itself, the ecclesiastical arm
controlling all the political powers
decked in purple and red and holding
this cup in her hand. I saw a woman sit
upon a scarlet colored beast full of the
names of blasphe blasphemy. Revelation
17:3
and the purple and the scarlet colors
and the gold and the precious stones.
Rome is the richest church institution
in the entire world. The treasures that
are in the Vatican museum boggle the
mind. It is unbelievable.
And in this golden cup there are all
these abominations of her false
teachings.
Now we have already seen that she is
called mystery. Now something that is a
mysterious or mystery is something that
works behind the scenes that is secret
and she is the mother mysteriously so of
all the other harlots as well. Does she
control all the churches in the world
that are apostate towards God? Is that a
possibility here? Well, we haven't
looked into that issue in great detail
yet, but we'll come to that in another
lecture. Revelation 17:E5,
the old Babylonian religion and the old
bull cult, all of these these ancient
religions. We will find all these
aspects in Rome.
2 Timothy 4:4 says they will turn away
from listening to the truth and give
their attention to legends. So the
church would eventually succumb and
instead of believing in salvation
through the lamb of God that was
sacrificed for the sins of the world,
they will have all kinds of notions
which will satisfy their own egos.
Psalms 116:13
says, "I will take the cup of salvation
and call upon the name of the Lord." So,
which is our choice? Are we going to use
the systems of the world and be
comfortable
or are we going to call upon the name of
the Lord and be ostracized? That's the
choice that we have.
the Tower of Babel, a woman calling
herself Babylon or the Bible calls her
Babylon. And all these features fit
together.
2 Thessalonians talks about this mystery
in chapter 2 7-10. For this mystery
of iniquity
does already work. So this stealthful
working was already working in the time
when this was written. When Paul pinned
these words, this power was already
working. Now, we've had lectures here
where we've looked at the early church
fathers with their corrupt gnostic ideas
and we've found them in all the Masonic
writings of the bishop of Alexandria of
Constantinople
and all of these with their Oregon
ideas. So, it was working even in Paul's
time. Gnosticism was rising. Elifas Levi
tells us that Simon Magus was the father
of the modern gnostic movement within
the church itself.
So this mystery was working in the time
of the apostles.
Only he who now letth will let until he
is taken out of the way. And then shall
the wicked be revealed whom the Lord
shall consume with the spirit of his
mouth. What does that mean? And shall
destroy with the brightness of his
coming, even him whose coming is after
the working of Satan
with all power and signs and lying
wonders,
and with all deceivleness of
unrighteousness in them that perish,
because they received not the love of
the truth, but that they might be saved.
powerful text tells us the circumstances
of the rise of this antichrist system
and it tells us that there was something
holding it back. So basically we could
read this as he who holds it back will
be taken out of the way and then shall
this wicked one be revealed. So
something is holding it back. the system
which was already working in in the time
of Paul but it would be taken away and
then this system would rise and it would
work with lying wonders
deceivableness
unrighteousness
and it will deceive the whole world
taking away the truth from people let's
have a look at this tremendous reference
in Paul's writings regarding the man of
sin
Now we beseech you, brethren, by c by
the coming of our Lord Jesus Christ, and
by our gathering together unto him, that
you be not soon shaken in mind, or be
troubled, neither by spirit, nor by
word, nor by letter, as from us, as that
day of Christ is at hand.
Jesus is not coming yet. That he said
Jesus is not here as some of you think.
He's not coming yet. It's not soon that
he's coming. Let no man deceive you by
any means,
for that day shall not come except there
come a falling away first
and that man of sin be revealed.
So Jesus's coming will not happen until
there is a falling away and the man of
sin is revealed. The son of pition.
Interesting word. The son of pition.
Used only twice in the Bible. Do you
know that? Used only twice in the Bible.
Only two have been called sons of
pition. The one is this man of sin, this
system, and the other one was Judas.
Now, if I'd like to ask you, how did
Judas betray Jesus
with a kiss? So, did he
present himself as one of them? Yes or
no? Isn't it possible that this system,
the son of pition, will also present
himself as a representative of Jesus
Christ and
betray everyone with a kiss? Isn't that
possible?
who opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called God or that is worshiped
so that he as God sits in the temple of
God showing himself that he is God and
we saw that the papacy actually did that
and this is that spirit of antichrist
whereof we have heard that it should
come even now already is in the world 1
John 4:3 so this power was working in
the time of John and in the time of the
apostles. This is not some future power
that as many believe that will come uh
sometime in the future as futurism
teaches in the world out there.
Remember ye not, Paul continues, that
when I was yet with you, I told you
these things,
and now you know what withholdeth
that he might be revealed in his time.
So Paul said to them, I told you that
something was withholding the
antichrist, preventing it from
developing,
and you know what it is. For the mystery
of iniquity doth already work. Only he
that now letth will let until he be
taken out of the way.
The uh BBE translation says there is one
who is keeping back that evil till he is
taken out of the way. So something was
withholding
this power from rising. And when that
something has been taken away then the
antichrist will come. And then shall the
wicked be revealed and the Lord shall
consume with the spirit of his mouth and
shall destroy with the brightness of his
coming. So God will fight against this
system with the word of God and finally
will destroy it at his coming. That's a
promise.
Even him whose coming is after the
working of Satan. And we have this text
again of how he works. So when will this
antichrist arrives? Paul told them that
something was withholding. We don't have
the facts here as to what it was. So
here Gratian Guinness Romanism and the
Reformation writes here we have a point
on which Paul affirms the existence of
knowledge in the Christian church. The
early church knew he says what the
hindrance was. The early church tells us
what it did know upon the subject. And
no one in these days can be in a
position to contradict its testimony as
to what Paul had by word of mouth only
told the Thessalonians.
Today we are saying what hindered it? It
was the Holy Spirit. It was that. It was
that. It was the other. No, we don't
know because Paul is the only one who
told them what was hindering it.
It is a point on which ancient tradition
alone can have authority. Modern
speculation is positively impertinent on
such a subject. That makes sense. Can
the early church fathers tell us what
Paul had told them what was holding it
back? Tertullian on the resurrection
chapter 24 this was written 200 AD says
the following. He who now hinders must
hinder un until he be taken out of the
way. What obstacle is there but the
Roman state? The falling away of which
by being scattered into 10 kingdoms
shall introduce Antichrist. Interesting.
So that's what the early church fathers
understood that when Rome finally
collapses
then antichrist will come. That's what
they believed. Let's continue. John
Christtom homaly on 2 Thessalonians that
was bishop of Constantinople 390 says
only there is one that restrainth now
until he be taken out of the way. That
is when the Roman Empire is taken out of
the way then he antichrist shall come.
There's another one that says it
interesting. Well Paul says the power
was already working then and sooner or
later he will arise. There's something
hindering it, but when it goes, I told
you what it was. Then it'll arise. Here
is Edward Ellen Elliot commentary on the
apocalypse. And it says, we have the
consenting testimony of the early
fathers from Irenaeus, the disciple of
St. John down to Christ the storm and
Jerome to the effect that it was
understood to be the imperial power
ruling and residing at Rome that had to
be taken out of the way.
Graten Guinness says, "While the Caesars
held imperial power, it was impossible
for the predicted antichrist to arise.
On the fall of the Caesars, he would
arise." That makes sense.
The biblical prophecies make sense. The
1,260day
prophecy makes sense. If you look at all
of these issues and uh while the Caesars
held imperial power, he would arise on
the fall of the Caesars. he would
arrive. Graten Guinness, Romanism and
the Reformation. There are numerous that
sources that say this. Paul did not
identify the restraining power which
they knew to be Rome for fear of
reprisals.
Remember the Christian church was under
persecution by Rome. So Paul wrote them
an epistle and he said, "What I told you
personally, you know what it is. That
must first happen. So don't go teaching
all kinds of doctrines. We're waiting
for the falling away, the man of sin,
the obstacle to be taken away, the man
of sin will arise, and then he will rule
on this earth. And then only eventually
will Christ come and he will consume
this power when he returns. That's the
biblical version.
1 Timothy 3:16 says, "And without
controversy, great is the mystery of
godliness.
God was manifest in the flesh. Will you
notice that
God was manifest in the flesh? Let's not
change that.
Justified in the spirit, seen of the
angels, preached unto the Gentiles,
believed on in the world, received up
into glory. That's the only mystery in
Christianity. No other mystery. We will
never comprehend how the God of the
universe could have become man for us,
died for us, and then save us, and make
us sons and daughters of the most high.
It's a mystery. We'll never understand
that. Everything else has been revealed
in its fullness. But this will remain
our study for all eternity. That is the
mystery of godliness, the mystery of
iniquity. wants to undo
this salient
eternal central fact of salvation. And
we have already seen in the lectures how
the efforts have been made to reduce the
workings of Jesus Christ and how through
the secret societies the ancient
Babylonian religion through cabalism
andnosticism
remove Jesus Christ as the deity that
saves and replaces it with another
power. We've seen the Islamic secret
societies and we see what seen what the
Quran teaches that Jesus was not the son
of God, that he never died, that his
blood was not shed for us, that he was
whisked away, that he's spiritualized,
he never came in the flesh. all of these
issues. We see this is the very central
doctrine of Rome today and is the
theology of the Vulgates,
the Templars, the Rosacruians, the
Jesuits, Freemasonry, all of them hold
to the central doctrine. Two doctrines
in the world, not a hundred, not 200,
not 300, and not 500. Two doctrines in
the world, all wearing different cloaks,
all controlled by one power.
Unbelievable.
Remember the story of Bell? We discussed
that the temple of Bell and where we saw
the woman with this nice little mini
skirt. You soon thought the miniskirt
was something new. No, no, no. It is
very old. There it is. And uh well this
lady of I don't know whether she was a
lady of the night or a lady of the day
but this lady with a golden cup in her
hand represents the worship of Baal
and uh Fides how fascinating sittes
we saw very interesting he has the
meaning of the worship of the goddess
the initiate Yates the insider initiates
were the fides and we wouldn't know what
that was if we didn't have this nice
quote from Albert G Mackey 33°ree
Freemason which says the right hand as
in all ages been deemed an emblem of
fidelity and our ancient brethren
worship deity under the name of Fides or
fidelity which was sometimes represented
by two right hands joined which is also
what Freemasonry does and sometimes by
two human figures holding each other by
the right hand. Numa was the first to
erect at the altar to Fides under which
name the goddess of oaths and honesty
was worshiped. Obligations taken in a
name were considered as more inviable
than any others. Here is a mystery. We
are showing you one side but we actually
teach another.
Morals and dogma page 292. You will
recall we had the secret symbols where
we had the PX over here which is on so
many preaching rosters and pulpits and
altars today and it's given Christian
connotations for the goyam for the
catacumans
but here the insider himself tells us it
is the staff of Osiris. So it is the
representation of the male member that
sits in the boat. Fine. And he also told
us that uh the various other symbols
that we see over here are pagan symbols.
The towel and uh this cross over here
and the swastikas this way or the other
way and the stars of David. And then
this interesting statement, the
vestments of the priests of Horus were
covered with these crosses. And then you
have the Maltese cross.
And I showed you that the papacy has
this on its vestments and the bishops
wear it as well. These are priests of
Horus. That's a mystery. You have to
look behind the scenes to find it. The
miter that they wear on their head that
today looks at represents actually the
fish head of the god dagon
which means dug on is the fish god. So
the fish head later the cape was removed
the fish cape it was replaced with a red
cloak or a purple cloak or whatever
color but the miter with the open fish
head on top remained there you see in
Babylonian relief in the paragon museum
you see the fish with the open mouth the
miter on the head of the priests of
Babylon and here they had pales with
water and they had little branches es of
his hop that they put in and they
sprinkled it upon the waters. And this
is exactly what the papacy does. The
bishops walk with their holy water. The
pope has a branch of his hop and he
sprays the people. This is Babylonian
ritual. This is cleansing through bab
lub
the gate lub
babel portal to God. Jesus says, "I am
the door. I am the gate." Jesus is the
gate. There is only one way to heaven,
and that is through acknowledging our
sinfulness
and accepting the vicarious sacrifice of
the son of God who died for us. That's
the only way there is to salvation. But
Babel says, "No, we have another portal
to God." That's a fascinating story.
We're going to have a look at that in
another lecture. Do you know how many
bobs there are in the world today? Oh,
they all call themselves Bob. Sai Bob.
Bob. Oh, you name it. Lots of Bobs out
there. We better watch out for all the
Bobs. Only one Bob
that leads to God, and that's Jesus.
Only one gate, only one portal. But
here's another form of cleansing. Jesus
says, "I will sprinkle you with his
soap." Papacy says, "No, no, no. I'll do
it. You'll be saved through the system.
No other way.
Two ideologies clash. The priests, they
were bowed down to. Their slippers were
kissed. Their rings were kissed. This is
paganism. There's the sign of Shamash,
which you will find
everywhere in the world today.
Unbelievable where you will find the
signs of Shamash.
The Gnostics founded by Simon Magus who
according to Elifas Levi became sorcerer
to Nero. History Leaga Magi page 199.
These are the very prominent sources.
Levi know people like to have that name
on the back of their whatever you know
very prominent.
And if you go to Rome this is a symbol
that you will find over there. This is
uh outside of that ancient pagan temple
where all uh religions were honored. And
on the bottom you have the square which
is masonic. Then you have the elephant
on top of that. And then you have this
symbol on top with a cross on top. And
everybody says that looks very nice.
Unless you know of course that the
square is the symbol or the cube of the
ancient deities and that the alf is the
alpha the alf the first letter the alant
which is the bull of the east. So in
Hinduism they still have the alf as the
symbol of the sun god. The first one in
the Hebrew it is the bull and on top of
it the missing piece of Osiris
and on top of that the towel. So you
have the full catastrophe of pagan
worship in this symbol over here in
Catholicism
and crimson and purple are the colors.
Isn't it fascinating that they believe
that we have the knowledge of good and
evil? So we will find that the pope will
always be dressed in white. He
represents the white side, the
Luciferian side. And his side man, his
sidekick if you like, the one who is the
military dictator of all of this will
wear which color?
Black. So the head of the Jesuit order
always wears black. so that you have
both sides of the knowledge of good and
evil. And the woman was arrayed in
purple and scarlet color and decked with
gold and precious stones and pearls,
having a golden cup in her hand, full of
the abominations of the filthiness of
her fornication. Strong language. If you
take the papal crown, the papal triple
crown that comes from Meo Persia, if you
had that crown alone, you could probably
get all the debt out of the United
States of America if you sold it.
And the priests that uh officiate, they
have the same colors and they of course
here celebrate the mass which is the
literal sacrificing of Jesus Christ
again and again and again and again.
Seated on the papal throne before the
main altar in St. Peter's, Pope Paul
listens to Cardinal Sunn's famous sermon
on Pope John delivered during the second
session of the council. The sermon
began. There was a man sent from God
whose name was John. Very interesting.
What happened at the second council?
Well, at the second council, all were
invited again into the sisterhood of the
churches except that Rome would be the
mother and everybody else could remain a
sister. Isn't that interesting?
Interesting.
Idolatry
was the the worship in the old system.
Idolatry is the same worship in the
present system. Exactly the same. But
idolatry takes many forms. Idolatry
doesn't mean just bowing down to a
statue. Idolatry could mean something
else as well. And wouldn't it be
interesting if we knew that Rome
actually controlled that aspect as well
in its totality
completely and utterly? Well, we cannot
today go into all the systems of
idolatry. That would be impossible. But
uh idolatry does not mean just bowing
down to an idol. You could have
different idols. What about world
sports?
And who controls world sports? Well, if
you look at the symbols that they have,
every single one of these super clubs
has a Masonic symbol. It's very
interesting. The greatest football team
in the world, Manchester United, even
uses the devil directly. Why not? Sounds
good to me.
Masonic ladders, Masonic chevrons,
uh, signs of shamash. Why not? These are
the greatest teams in the world.
And what about all of these? We have
animals of darkness. We have flying
horses, which is Pegasus.
We have all these interesting symbols
with pentagrams and uh shields of Malta
and sun symbols and pentagrams and
double-headed lions and goats. All the
symbols and flu de
you name it, we have it. Masonic M,
Masonic anchors, the whole shooting
match. The Masonic fingers, the
skull and bones, Titan is actually
Satan's Greek name. So, we have all
these interesting features. The G, we
anybody who's a Freemason will know that
that comes from the Masonic lodge. If we
go to Exodus
32:2-6, and Aaron said to them, "Break
off the golden earrings which are in the
ears of your wives,
of your sons and of your daughters."
Well, today earrings are very popular.
"And bring them to me," he made a golden
calf. And the Aaron made proclamation
and said, "Tomorrow is a feast of
Jehovah." And they rose up early the
next day and offered burnt offerings and
brought peace offerings. And the people
sat down to eat and drink and rose up to
play. Now, what did they play?
What did you think they played?
Well, part of the system of sun worship
was to play sports.
What kind of sport did they play? That's
very interesting. Well, let's go to
UNESCO.
They should know because the UNESCO
um
manifest as you know was written by a
skull and bones member. So he must be an
interesting insider. And he writes for
example polo was known to the Persians
and restored to its original sun game
significance by Akbar. Scoring a goal
with a sun ball was equated with a
triumph of light over darkness, good
over evil. But remember that masonry
calls light darkness and darkness light
and calls Jesus and Jehovah evil.
So the triumph of light over darkness
represented in paganism the triumph of
Lucifer
over Jesus Christ.
So the triumph of darkness
over darkness, good over evil. The ball
is the sun symbol in all shut sports as
football, hockey, basketball, cricket.
Baseball is related to the sun and the
sundial shape and the pattern of the
field as well as its rules of play and
scoring. Like all sports, baseball also
embodies the sun's seasonal cycle in
much the same way as ancient ceremonial
contests were held as part of fertility
rights. So if you can't get them to the
church, get them to the sports field.
Isn't that interesting? And in the
church, you see the arms going like
this. And on the sports field, you see
the arms going like this. Hymns are sung
in the church. Hymns of a different
nature are sung over there. It's quite
fascinating. Who cares as long as he has
worship?
Sumerian Gilgamesh story inscribed in
uniform tablets narrates how the
sporting equipment, a stick and a ring
or a ball which Gilgamesh had carved out
of the uprooted tree had fallen into the
netherworld as he began oppressing his
people by repeated athletic
competitions. Now eventually it was the
sun god who opened a hole in the ground
in order to recover them.
So if you had a stick and you had a
ball, if you took the stick and you got
the ball into the hole, that was a
simple. It has a deeper meaning than
what we really believe. Actually, it's
quite a meaning, but forget about that.
That's what golfers do, for example.
You know, it's amazing. And how often we
are told that this is marvelous and it's
good for Christianity and all these
things. I have nothing against sports.
Sport is a good recreation. Sport is
good for exercise. There are things that
you can do with sport that are good. But
if sport becomes a religion,
isn't that problematic? Isn't that
idolatry? The Olympic torch, which the
runner carries to mark the sun's cyclic
movement through the Olympiad, the
four-year period until the next games,
is also related to the sun's cyclic
rhythm. First celebrated in Greece, the
name was ceremonial contest nonovas. Did
you see the opening ceremony?
Now, the Greek one, didn't they honor
the gods? Yes or no? Yes. And we go off
we go. Well, sun, moon, and other
planets float overhead. Barcelona,
Olympic games. The sun's association
with sports predates the deities
Heracles and Apollo in Greece, as is
evident from the epic tale of the
Samrian hill hero Gilgamesh.
Fascinating stuff. As in sport, the sun
is omniresent on practically all aspects
of life. Whether it be art,
architecture, philosophy, religion,
festivals, folklore, dance, music. Wow,
he's got every base covered.
Every morning, a pagan god of the day
wakes us up. For the Romans in the early
century of Christian era named each day
after the seven planets, sun, moon,
Mars, Mercury, Jupiter, Venus, and
Saturn. If we look at the symbols of the
Olympics, you'll see they've got baladad
symbol, baladad symbol, baladad symbol,
baladad symbol, baladad symbol. You can
find them all over there. This is
paganism.
Here is a young man bringing a fine
hockey shirt to the pope. Let's see what
he will do with it.
A fine hockey shirt.
Wow, that's a blessed shirt.
So,
Freemasonry controls all these issues
for Rome today. The sporting world, the
religious world. This is fascinating.
I wonder how much idolatry is hidden in
the mystery and how much more the Bible
wants to reveal about this amazing story
of Revelation 17.
Let us wait for a further episode to
find out.
This is a picture
of
St. John's Lateran.
Now St. John's Lateran
is the main church in Rome, not St.
Peter's. That's where the papacy is
active and does all its major things.
But this is where the pope is crowned.
And this is where he speaks Excedra.
Uh again, please note that it's called
St. John's remember I've told you before
about the St. John's secret of the
Templars and how they were Johnites,
Yansenites if you like.
The wine of her fornication, the mother
of the churches, Imatlesia.
Revelation 17:5 says she is the mother
of prostitutes. Revelation 18:7 says, "I
sit as queen. I am not a widow. I will
never mourn."
And Isaiah 47:8 says, "I am," that's
God, "and there is none beside me. I
will never be a widow or suffer loss of
children." So if church is separated
from her, maybe she'll get them back.
She says, "I will not suffer loss."
Dominus
other churches are no sisters of ours.
The Vatican ex insists. September 5,
2000, the Independent.
Well, the church of Rome fulfills every
single prophecy.
It must always be clear that the one
holy, Catholic, and apostolic universal
church is not the sister but the mother
of all the churches. Cardinal Ratzinger
942000.
He makes it pretty plain. Cardinal
Ratzinger is the head for the foundation
of doctrine and faith which is the old
inquisition.
Definition of incredul, heresy,
apostasy. There is no graver offense
than heresy and therefore it must be
rooted out with fire and the sword.
That's what the Catholic Encyclopedia
said in 1911.
The Catholic Catechism says incredul is
the neglect of revealed truth or the
willful refusal to ascent to it. Heresy
is the obstinate postbaptismal denial of
some truth which must be believed with
divine and Catholic faith.
So if the pope has said something and
you say I don't believe it, you're a
heretic must be rooted out with fire and
the sword. Well, Protestantism said
that. I don't want to accept that
anymore. It said I will not believe it.
And so the Western Watchmen in 1914 said
Protestantism is not a religion. Never
was a religion. The most that could be
said about it was that was a form of
rape and robbery masquerading as a
religion. There was a problem there. The
Council of Trent called by Pope Paul III
between 1545 and 1563
met in three sessions. Protestants were
present during the second meeting. I'll
be dealing with this in a greater detail
in another uh lecture. But it's
fascinating to see that the council
reaffirmed the doctrines disputed by the
reformists. Every single doctrine. And
there was a specific reason why they did
so. Why the reformation lost at the
Council of Trent. Fascinating story, but
it's too long to discuss now. Doctrines
reaffirmed or transubstantiation
that the body of Christ literally is
formed during the mass. Justification by
faith and works. The medieval mass was
upheld. The second seven sacraments.
Celibacy. Doctrine of purgatory. We see
this now in the modern Bibles reaffirmed
again. Indulgences were reaffirmed and
papal power was increased.
So all power now in one man. So after
the council of Trent truly there was all
power in one man which is called
ultraontinism
and truly the pope represents as the man
of sin which is transgression of the
law. Well, what if you change the law?
Then you not only transgress it, you
have the audacity to change it.
So here we have a full system as the
Bible says it would be
transubstantiation.
Marvelous dignity of the priests in
their hands as in the womb of the
blessed virgin Mary, the son of God
becomes incarnate. Behold the power of
the priest, the tongue of the priest
makes God from a morsel of bread. It is
more than creating the world.
So they feel pretty good about that.
Canon one says if anyone, this is
Council of Trent session 13, if anyone
denies that in the sacrament of the most
holy Eucharist are contained truly,
really substantially the body and blood
together with the soul and divinity of
our Lord Jesus Christ and consequently
the whole Christ, but says that he's
only in it is in a sign or a figure or a
force. Let him be an anathema. There's a
problem. I going to along go along with
that because Jesus Christ
was sacrificed
because by one sacrifice he has made
perfect forever those who are being made
holy. Hebrews 10:14.
So I have a problem with this statement.
So when we celebrate the mass in the
Roman Catholic sense, this is not
remembering the Lord till he comes. This
is wine of her fornication. Right or
wrong? And what it does, it nails Jesus
Christ, Jesus Christ to the cross
perpetually.
He stays there all the time. He's
crucified again and again and again and
again. That's why their symbol too is
the crucifix because that's they where
they would like Jesus to stay on the
cross. But my Jesus is no longer on a
cross. He is in heaven and he is coming
back as king of kings and lord of lords.
Remember the forgiveness of sins. Luke
5:21. Blasphemy. If you say that you as
a man can forgive sin.
forgiveness of sins.
The Son of Man has authority on earth to
forgive sins. He said to the paralytic,
"I say to you, arise and take up your
cot and go to your house." Jesus proved
that he had that authority. But the
priest has the power of the keys, the
power of delivering sinners from hell
and making them worthy of paradise and
by changing them from slaves of Satan
into children of God. God himself is
obliged obligated to abide by the
judgment of his priests and either not
to pardon or to pardon. We saw that
yesterday. These are wine doctrines of
fornication. Mary the mediatrics. Now
Jesus disappears.
1854 Pope Pas declared Mary immaculate.
1951 he defined and enforced the
doctrine of the bodily assumption to
Mary. Catholic layman says, "The sinner
that ventures directly to Christ may
come with dread and apprehension of his
wroth, but let him only employ the
mediation of the virgin with her son,
and she has only to show that son the
breasts that gave him suck, and his
wroth will immediately be appeased."
What a stupid doctrine. It's really
disgusting.
I could show you slides where I've been
in the milk grotto. Anybody know about
the milk grotto in uh Bethlehem?
where the milk of Mary is squirted up
against the walls and it's a holy place
authenticated by the pope.
This is ancient fertility right
paganism.
Imagine a son today if the mother was
angry with him or he was angry with the
mother and she bared her breast. What
would he think? You think mother have
you gone insane?
That is paganism. This is fertility
cult. These are statements by the
Catholic saints. He falls and is lost
who has no not recourse to Mary.
Mary is called the gate.
Hold it. Jesus says, I am the door.
There's no other way, says Jesus. Gate
of heaven because no one can enter that
blessed kingdom without passing through
her. The way of salvation is open to
none otherwise than through Mary. The
salvation of all depends on the being
favored and protected by Mary. He who is
protected by Mary will be saved. He who
will who is not will be lost. Our
salvation depends on thee. God will not
save us without the intercession of
Mary.
Well, tell us is that not wine of his
fornication.
The pope says Mary must be a goddess.
Maria Gatin.
Then the the dogma of the assumption. We
dealt with this issue. I'm just showing
it to you now in Revelation to see how
it all fits together. We've dealt with
all these issues already.
Tradition, infallibility, and the
scriptures. Bonaventure Henwood papal
spokesman. More answers to your
questions. It tells us that the pope is
infallible. The Bible, we've dealt with
this issue. The index of prohibited
books, the textus receptus is
prohibited,
but the Jesuit version is not.
Well, we dealt with this issue. We had a
whole lecture on it. Isn't this wine of
his fornication?
Isn't this making Jesus less than he is?
Septugant was made for the Alexandrian
library. Here is this uh theologian
Paul Netta. Who is he? Paul Nitar served
as divine word missionary before
assuming position at Zavia University
where is present presently professor of
theology. Where did he study at the
pontipical Gregorian university that's
the biggest Jesuit university in Rome
and studied under Krana. Who was Krana?
Kalano was the Jesuit who was put in
charge of making all the churches
subject to Rome. Again, we'll be dealing
with that in a later lecture. He writes
a book, No Other Name.
And then he goes to show that you can be
saved any way you want to. Any way you
want to. Whatever you want to be saved
by, go for it. Hello. Isn't this wine of
a fornication
world religion? Masonic signals, Dalai
Llamas,
crosses, bent crosses. Did you know that
that's the same cross that Satanists use
with an emassiated Jesus on there with a
V sign over there? The Masonic triangle
hanging on this bent cross. This is
Luciferianism.
And they use IHS. They say it means
homminum salv. Some say it means any
service. No, it means Isis Horus Seb the
Egyptian trinity. If you look at the the
outer court, it's a circle within a
circle, a wheel within a wheel. It is
the eight spokes of the wheel of the
solar system or the solar deities with
the
Osiris missing part right in the middle.
Fascinating
Mitra, killing the bull. Victory over
evil. Evil remember esoterically is fi
defined as Jesus. Here's the structure
of the cult. Members went through seven
grades each of which had special symbol
of tutery planet from the lowest of the
highest who was Korox the raven on the
mercury. Nymphus notice this interesting
nymphus a madeup word meaning male bride
under Venus. That means when you were
initiated into this priesthood, you
became a male bride.
Celibate.
Does Rome do that? Yes.
But as the male bride, you do not have
to be as celibate as some think. So
let's not go into those details. Milles
the soldier on the Mars. Leo the lion
under Jupiter. Persus the Persian under
Luna the moon. Heldus the son's coua
under soul the sun. And finally pat
father under Saturn
it was possible for methraic initiate to
be a member of more than one cult. Women
were not permitted to become members.
This is Catholicism. Roman Catholicism
is mitriism.
This is the Persian aspect of it. Here
is the occult arm. These are the
wandering bishops. They control
occultism in the world. The deep secrets
of the occults,
all things to all men. There the pope
receives the tilak. He receives the
bindi, the red mark on the for which is
the sign of sa and sa is Lucifer.
And here he kisses the Quran. All things
to all men. The Bible says Revelation
17:2, with whom the kings of the earth
have committed fornication.
Well, here they are from the fall leazar
in front of the pope. We look at the
kings of the world that have created
havoc upon this planet dealings with the
papacy. We see the garbachoffs with the
papacy. We see the so-called dictators
with the papacy actually part and parcel
of it. Why do they always wear black
when they visit the pope? because they
have to reflect the two sides of the
Masonic story, the knowledge of good and
evil. The queen of the Bilderberers,
Prince Phillip, will have some
interesting things to say about him.
Prince Charles in his black with a white
pope. And here we have the equivalence
in the Islamic world. Black tie, at
least he's got that on and black socks.
There is Margaret Thatcher. There is
Carter, the Japanese,
the Bushes, and the Blaires.
Do the kings of the world work with this
system? Yes or no? Is there any system
on this planet that qualifies like this
system? Ignatius
under them together. And if you're
thinking about voting,
well, that simply means that the battle
will be between this young man over here
and this young man over here. And
they're both Skull and Bolds members.
So, who cares who wins the next
election? Who cares?
Revelation 17:6. And I saw the woman
drunken with the blood of the saints and
with the blood of the martyrs of Jesus.
That's Revelation 17:6. Well, there it
is. Bartholomewite, the Valtenzas,
the 30-year war, the 100redyear war, the
bloodshed,
Stalin, you name it. What they did to
God's people. Unbelievable.
They slaughtered them left, right, and
center. The Inquisition, Thomas Aena
said, the convicted heretic should be
put to death as surely as other
criminals. The Catholic Church is a
respector of conscience and of liberty.
Nevertheless, when confronted with
heresy, she has recourse to force, to
corporal punishment, to torture. She lit
in Italy the funeral piles of the
Inquisition. This is the only system
that qualifies. We've already dealt with
the Jesuit oath. I'm not going to read
that oath again. The terrible tortures
for heresy who shall believe and
practice what they want to decide for
themselves. deciding for oneself what
one shall believe.
Revelation 17 gives us more information.
Revelation 17:7, "And the angel said
unto me, wherefore did thou marvel? I
will tell thee the mystery of the woman,
and of the beast that carrith her, which
has the seven heads, and the 10 horns."
So, let's discuss it a little bit more.
The beast that thou sawest was
and is not and shall ascend. The lamb of
God once was,
then he was not and then he will come
again. Isn't that right? So it's a
counterfeit of Christ. This system puts
itself in the place of Jesus Christ. So
this political power, this beast which
thou sawest was and is not and shall
ascend out of the bottomless pit and go
into pition.
And they that dwell on the earth shall
wonder whose names were not written in
the book of life from the foundation of
the world when they behold the beast
that was and is not and yet is. That's
an interesting statement. There's been
much speculation on this and let's try
and unravel it and see if we can come up
with something. I don't want to be
dogmatic, but let's see what we can get.
Is not stage.
In 1798,
the beast received a mortal wound. Is
that correct? So, the beast once was, it
ruled over the middle ages. Then it is
not. It died.
It seemed to have a mortal wound and
then it will come again. Is that right?
So let's look at this is not stage. 1798
it received a mortal wound. What did it
do in secrecy clandestinely when it was
supposedly dead? Well 1854 the dogma of
the immaculate conception. In 1870
infallibility
in 1929
he crowned himself sovereign ruler of
the world. 1951 the assumption of Mary
current Mary is advocate mediator and
co-redeemer that's totally replacing
Jesus Christ what a system that
developed in that time revelation 17:9
and here is the mind which has wisdom
the seven heads are seven mountains
oros mountain on which the woman siteth
now besides the fact that Rome is built
on seven hills
That is an interesting point. There are
other issues as well. The number seven
is also part of those kingdoms. Remember
and there are seven kings. So now we
have a king and a kingdom coming
together. Five are fallen. One is the
other is not yet come. And when he
cometh he must continue a short space.
And the beast that was and is not, even
he is the eighth and is of the seven and
goes into pition. That's a jawbreaker
for those who like puzzles.
Let's have a look at the heads or
mountains. In the Bible, they symbolize
empires, not individual kings. And I
will render unto Babylon and to all the
inhabitants of Calaldia all their evil
that they have done in Zion in your
sight, says the Lord. Behold, I am
against you, oh destroying
mountain,
says the Lord, which destroyth all the
earth, and I will stretch out mine hand
upon thee, and rolled thee down from the
rocks, and will make thee a burnt
mountain. This is a reference to Babylon
that was going to attack
God's people. So, a mountain is a
kingdom.
So, let's identify the seven heads. Uh,
I don't intend to be dogmatic at all and
I don't believe it's a question of
salvation whether you have it right or
whether you don't. Questions of
salvation
refer to your relationship with Jesus
Christ and nothing else. So whether we
have them exactly right or not, it
doesn't really matter. But God gives us
information. Let's look at it. It's
interesting.
Interpretation one, if we look at it
from the time of John,
the seven heads represent the principal
persecuting powers of God's people over
the ages. This is one interpretation.
Five have fallen. They say Egypt,
Assyria, Babylon, Meo, Persia, and
Greece.
Five have fallen.
One is well looking at it from the time
of John that would be Rome. The other is
not yet come. That's the papacy. That's
one interpretation that's quite popular
and many people adhere to it. And I have
no problem if anybody wants to adhere to
it because we end up with this final
power which obviously is the one that
causes all the problems. The only
problem that I have with this
interpretation is which powers do you
leave out over here? Because Egypt,
Assyria, Babylon, Meo, Persia, Greece
are the ones that are mentioned and
you're starting with the time of John.
So that's an assumption you make in
order to unravel this prophecy.
But which ones do you leave out? For
example, if you go to Ezekiel 16:26 and
you look at the enemies of God, you had
the Egyptians, you had the Philistines,
you had the Assyrians, you had the
Calaldanss. So, in that interpretation,
the Philistines, for example, are left
out. What if I didn't want to leave them
out? Then my numbers would be wrong,
right?
So, personally, I don't have a problem
with the main structure, but the details
don't quite satisfy me. Identification
of the seven heads interpretation two
using Daniel now as a template which
seems to be logical because the book of
revelation uses the symbolism in the
book of Daniel to transfer it to this
situation that it describes in
revelation. So using Daniel as a
template some start with Babylon and
count from the time of the events
portrayed in revelation 17. So again you
have to make a decision. Now where do we
start with the events starting in
revelation 17 five have fallen Babylon
Meo Persia Greece
Rome papacy
one is
the wounded papacy now you're starting
with the time in revelation 17 where he
says one is so that's the time so they
get to Babylon me Persia Greece Rome
papacy one is that would be the wounded
papacy.
Not yet come would be the final
confederacy under the papacy because his
mortal wound will heal and all the world
will follow him. So that's a nice
interpretation. I have no major problem
with that. Only have one little
question. What about the other powers
mentioned in the book of Revelation? How
do you fit them in? Then then you have
to leave out some of the other beasts,
the two-horned beast and uh all of
those.
So what do we do to incorporate them?
And the angel said unto me, wherefore
did thou marvel? I will tell thee the
mystery of the woman and of the beast
that carrith her which has seven heads
and 10 horns. The beast which thou saw
was
is not shall ascend. Where does it
descend from?
bottomless pit. Ah, now which other
beast descended from the bottomless pit?
The one in Revelation chapter 11.
Remember that? The one that starts
making war on the word of God. The whole
philosophy of the French Revolution, all
of that. Go into pition and they that
dwell on the earth shall wonder whose
names were not written in the book of
life from the foundations of the world.
when they behold the beast that was is
not yet is.
Seven kings, five are fallen. And then
you have this little bit of information
here. And the other is not yet come. And
when he comes, he must continue a short
space. And the beast that was and is not
even he is the eighth
and is of the seven and goes into
pition. Aha. Little bit more detail. So
the eighth he goes into pition.
Actually, the eighth is part of the
seven. Let's fit that together.
Interpretation number three,
using Daniel as a template,
let's start with Babylon and count from
the time of the events portrayed in
Revelation 17. So much like the previous
one. So, five are fallen. Babylon, Meo,
Persia, Greece,
Rome, papacy. That's a religopolitical
power that ruled over the Middle Ages.
So
that's where you get to starting with
the events portrayed in Revelation 17.
One is a seemingly wounded papacy
is not it says yet is it seemed to have
a mortal wound. Do you remember that?
And we saw that it actually grew and
that the Jesuit organizations built up a
whole world empire in that time.
Communism, all these things developed in
this note stage. So seemingly wounded
papacy is not yet. That's a non-relig
religical powers run by secret papal
societies arising from the bottomless
pit in Revelation 11. That's what
happened during the not yet phase.
Not yet come. The image of the beast.
That's the religio political confederacy
under the lamblike beast.
The eighth is of the seven. That would
be a new world order, a final world
confederacy under the papacy.
Now, this one is not much different from
the previous one. And whether we like
the previous one or this one, it doesn't
really matter to me personally.
That's how I would like to put it
together myself, but I'm not hooked on
it. I mean, it doesn't really matter as
long as the final one ends up to be the
papacy because he arises then and he
goes to pition. But this one for me
includes all the images that we have in
the book of Revelation. So this is what
I presume it might mean.
And the 10 horns which thou sourced are
10 kings which have received no kingdom
as yet.
So if this is the stage where we're
talking this is not stage and there are
10 that have not yet received a kingdom
and that's future. Then what does this
10 stand for? But receive power as kings
one hour with the beast. There must be
some confederacy. So 10 could mean the
number of completeness, all the kingdoms
of the world giving their power to the
beast. Or it could mean something else.
These have one mind and shall give their
power and strength unto the beast.
And these shall make war with the lamb.
This is the persecuting power at the
end. And the lamb shall overcome them.
For he is lord of lords and king of
kings, and they are with him. and they
that are with him are called and chosen
and faithful. So here's the final battle
that will take place.
On September 17, 1973,
the Club of Rome published a special
highly confidential report called the
regionalized and adaptive model of the
global world system. Fascinating stuff.
which was sent to the power elite to be
implemented.
This document reveals that the club has
divided the world into 10 political
economic regions which it refers to as
kingdoms.
A designation that tracks eerily with
the terminology used in the book of
revelation chapter 13 1-2. In 1974, the
authors of the report Malio Mazeric blah
blah blah blah pastel published their
final findings in a book mankind at the
turning point. However, in this book
which is intended for public
consumption, they have dropped the word
kingdom. This comes from a very good
source and route to global occupation
Gary H. So the world is being divided
into 10 regions. Did you know that there
are certain monarchies left and certain
royal families in the world? Some
interesting stuff that we might be
talking about in the next lectures to
come. And he says unto me, the waters
which thou sour, where the horse
sitters, are peoples, multitudes,
nations, and tongues, the 10 horns which
thou sour
upon the beast.
These shall hate the and shall
make her desolate and naked, and shall
eat her flesh, and burn her with fire.
Wow.
So first we have the kingdoms of the
world giving their power unto this beast
unto this religious system and then this
religious system goes and makes war
against God's people. What happens next?
Any idea?
God puts a hedge around his people. He
protects them. He holds them in the palm
of his hand just like he did in Egypt.
And they legislate against them. They
cannot buy, they cannot sell, they can
do nothing. Your bread and your water
shall be sure. A thousand shall fall by
your side. 10,000 at your right hand, it
will not come near you. All the promises
of God apply. Eventually they try in
their anger to eradicate this group that
clings to doctrines contrary to world
doctrines
and God sends plagues
and there is much suffering on earth and
God's people are hedged.
Eventually even these powers realize
that they have been what? duped
and they turn with bitter hatred and
aggression and destroy the very one that
tried to destroy God's people. That's
what it says. That's what it says.
Fascinating stuff. Now, notice very
interestingly
that they burn her with fire.
What was the punishment in the Old
Testament
for a that was caught in
fornication?
She was stoned. She was stoned to death.
But this one is burnt with fire. What
was the punishment
for the daughter of a priest that was
caught in prostitution?
>> She was burnt. Isn't this interesting?
See the analogies. Boy, the Bible is a
fascinating book. Anybody tell me that
humans thought this book up
and I will tell you I will eat that
beamer and my computer if this is so.
For God has put it into their hearts
permissive will of God because these
kings are lost too to fulfill his will
and to agree and to give their kingdom
unto the beast until the words of God
shall be fulfilled. And the woman which
thou source is that great city which
reignth over the kings of the earth.
This great Babylon controlled by the
of Babylon. Come hither, I will
show unto thee the judgment of the great
hall that siteth upon many waters,
with whom the kings of the earth have
committed fornication, and the
inhabitants of the earth have been made
drunk with the wine of a fornication.
That's the ending of the matter. So my
question to you tonight is, do we fear
the system to the point of obeying it or
do we cling to God? What's our choice?
Why would we be so stupid to go with the
system if this is what's going to happen
to the system? We would be fools not to
follow God. Besides the fact that God
God has a beautiful character that never
forces anyone and only draws, that God
is full of loving kindness and
gentleness. Why would I be so stupid to
want to follow this system?
Jeremiah 50:24 says, "I have laid a
snare for thee, and thou also taken, oh
Babylon, and thou was not aware, thou
art found, and also caught because thou
has striven against the Lord." That was
the typology. The Lord has opened his
armory, and has brought forth the
weapons of his indignation. For this is
the work of the Lord, God of hosts in
the land of the Calaldanss. come against
her from the utmost border upon her
storehouses. Cast her up as heaps and
destroy her utterly. Let nothing of her
be left. Slay all her bullocks. Let them
go down to the slaughter. Woe unto them
for their days come in the time of their
visitation. God is going to end that
system.
The voice of them that flee and escape
out of the land of Babylon to declare in
Zion the vengeance of the Lord our God,
the vengeance of his temple. Call
together the archers against Babylon.
All ye that bend the bow, camp against
it, or roundabout. Let none thereof
escape. Nobody's going to escape. This
is the typology. The final will be the
antitype.
Recompense her according to her work,
the millions that have died as a
consequence of her, according to all
that she has done. Do unto her. For she
has been proud against the Lord, against
the Holy One of Israel. Therefore shall
a young man for all her men of war shall
be cut off in that day says the Lord.
Behold I am against you. Oh thou m thou
most proud says the Lord God of hosts
for thy day is come. The time that I
will visit thee. This system is going to
end. And the most proud shall stumble
and fall and none shall raise him up.
And I will kindle a fire in its cities
and it shall devour all around him.
Amazing stuff. Their redeemer is strong.
These from Judah, the children of Judah
were oppressed together. The children of
God will be oppressed at the end of
time. And all that took them captive,
held them fast. They refused to let them
go.
Their redeemer is strong. He's stronger
than them. The Lord of hosts is his
name. He shall thoroughly plead their
cause that he may give rest to the land
and disqu the inhabitants of Babylon. A
sword is upon the Calaldanss, says the
Lord, and upon the inhabitants of
Babylon, upon our princes, and upon our
wise men. None of their wisdom is going
to help them. Isaiah 26 says, "Come, my
people, enter thou into thy chambers,
and shut thy doors about thee. Hide
thyelves as as it were for a little
moment until the indignation be
overpassed." The Lord is going to punish
Babylon, and God's people will be taken
care of. For behold, the Lord cometh out
of his place to punish the inhabitants
of the earth for their iniquity.
The earth also shall disclose her blood,
and shall no more cover her slain. There
will be a resurrection. Isaiah 26 verse
20 and 21. In that day, the Lord with
his sore and great strong sword will
punish Leviatan.
the piercing serpent, even leviatan,
that crooked serpent, and he shall slay
the dragon that is in the sea. That's
the biblical story, the most amazing
story that has ever unfolded in the
history of the world. Revelation 19:1.
And after these things, I heard a great
voice of much people in heaven, saying,
"Hallelujah!
Salvation and glory and honor and power
unto the Lord of our God. For true and
righteous are his judgments, for he has
judged the great which did
corrupt the earth with her fornication,
and has avenged the blood of his
servants at her hand." Isn't that
fascinating?
Revelation 19:19. Let's see what happens
to her. I saw the beast
and the kings of the earth and their
armies gathered together to make war
against him that sat on the horse and
against his army. So here they come and
the beast Catholicism was taken and with
him the false prophet
sad. Who's that? We'll have to wait for
another episode.
that wrought miracles before him. Well,
I can tell you who that was. Who was
that that wrought the miracles before
him? It was the Protestant world. It was
in the United States that the fire came
down and the miracles were done and that
the religious system, the image of the
beast enforced the papal doctrines.
We've dealt with it. Might as well deal
with it. With which he deceived them
that had received the mark of the beast
and them that worshiped his image. These
both were cast live into the lake of
burning with brimstone. There's only one
missing here. That's the dragon. He gets
dealt with later. And the remnant was
slain with the sword of him that sat
upon the horse, which sword proceeded
out of his mouth, and all the fowls were
filled with their flesh. Don't mess with
God. You'll end up here.
Revelation 19:6.
And I heard as it were the voice of a
great multitude and as the voice of many
waters as the voice of a mighty
thunderings saying allelujah for the
Lord God omnipotent reigns. That's the
end of the matter and we have nothing to
fear. Nothing.
>> In the next lecture we're going to look
at the new world order and we're going
to look at some of these issues that are
taking place in the world today. It is
frightening stuff, but nevertheless,
when you see these things happening,
lift up your eyes, for you know that
your redemption drawth nigh. Trust in
the Lord Jesus and fear nothing.
>> Thank you.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
I don't
know.